invest in yourself if you want to have
success as an entrepreneur then take the
time to invest in yourself and learning
and developing skills and seeing if
entrepreneurship is for you so that when
you go and start your business or when
you're trying to grow it you have a
skill set you have experience you have
knowledge that will give you the best
chance of success otherwise if you just
jump into something have no idea what
you're doing and hope it's going to work
out chances are it's not hope is not the
greatest strategy today maintain a
question from one of my readers Jacob
who wrote a really long email Jacob this
is great but we got to cut this down
anyway I read the whole thing so Jacob
is a student and basically wants to
start a business and one is some ideas
on how to get more learning so he says
he watches my videos all he's doing so
far as watch my videos and doing some
research so thank you for watching all
my videos that's great to hear a love
scene from the fans if you can give me
some advice I'll greatly appreciate it
so a couple things to you Jacob first
number one most important keep watching
the videos you'll learn a lot from this
and when I talk about entrepreneurship
but if there's other people that you
like as well I started creating these
videos because entrepreneurs were asking
me questions and I want to be able to
help more than just that one person
stead of just writing a response back
actually giving it a response on video
so other people could learn from it as
well but number two this is really
important I would try to find a famous
entrepreneur who you look up to who you
respect for whatever reason and learn
about them read their bio look about
their stories online you know if it's
Richard Branson Steve Jobs Donald Trump
Oprah Winfrey whoever it is find their
story the bigger the entrepreneur is the
more informational having them this is
what helped inspire me to not only start
my business but also give myself the
best chance of success because you see
these guys and they started from nothing
they had a passion for what they were
doing they had a product or service they
believed in and they went out and they
started selling and they had the odds
stacked against them so many things went
wrong you know you look at these stories
now you look at some famous
printer now and you think it was easy
for them but they started from nothing
they were just like you and me started
from nothing and those stories at least
for me inspired me and also gave me
practical tips advice suggestions on
what I could actually do by looking at
their stories I got ideas for what I
could do and the third thing I'll
suggest for you is try to go work for an
entrepreneur if you're discovering first
of all is entrepreneurship for you and
then second of all what kind of business
you want to run go get some experience
working for an entrepreneur so you know
try to think about an interview that
you're passionate about I don't know if
you've already thought about what kind
of business you want to start or not but
go find somebody who's working in your
business who start who started a company
that you respect and admire and maybe
you see yourself running that kind of
company some day but still small so if
you're thinking about maybe becoming a
graphic designer go work for graphic
design shop find a small shop ten people
try to get as close to the entrepreneur
owner as possible entrepreneurs are are
busy right we have so many projects on
the go and if it a great employee comes
along and wants to get involved in
projects beyond what they were hired for
the entrepreneur is always going to say
yes so get as close as you can to the
entrepreneur learning how they got
started learning how they grew their
business learning how they bring on more
customers take on projects beyond your
scope beyond what you were hired for
you're getting paid to learn about the
business and you'll find out one is this
what you want do you want to be an
entrepreneur do you like this person's
lifestyle do you want that for you and
two is this business for you you thought
you're gonna be a graphic designer but
now you got involved in the business I
thought nah this isn't for me I want
something else go find another job again
small company related to something that
you're interested in that way when
you're ready to go start your business
you have all the information that you
need you've been watching the videos and
you get lots of experience from that new
knowledge you've been reading up on
famous entrepreneurs and their stories
you get inspired by them you know what
next steps to take you see what they had
to do to grow their business and then
you have some practical hands-on
experience working for a company
who's doing what you want to do you're
building up your your contacts your
network your knowledge base so when
you're ready to launch your business you
can hit the ground running it'll
dramatically increase your chance of
success it'll dramatically increase your
probability of picking a business that
you love doing where you can have an
impact in the world where you can build
something that people will rally around
increase the chances you're making a lot
of money and increase a chance you're
going to be doing something that you're
really happy about get going believe for
those of you watching you like the video
please give it a thumbs up below it
makes me do more for you and I want to
hear what you have to think please leave
a comment under this video and makes my
morning every day when I load up the
comments and see what's coming in really
you guys are awesome for me so you give
me my motivational boost every day so
please leave a comment below if you
liked it and if you have a question for
your business leave it there i'll make a
video apply for you guys thank you and
I'll see you soon